what would you say has had the largest
Roi out of all of those things running a
business having a vlog doing a podcast
because it's like you only have so much
time in a day right I got a wife I got
to keep happy at some point all right
yes you do I say start with whatever you
have the best flow with so if you put
the camera up and you sit down in front
of the camera and you can Zone into the
camera and you can really go for it with
sit down videos then I say start there
but if you don't Vibe with sit down
videos and you pick up your Vlog camera
and you feel a little bit more
comfortable start with Vlogs vlogging is
a long-term game it's not like something
that you're probably gonna see immediate
results immediate growth from